doesn't matter
hey guys I'm Ryan right dance Seibert
and I'm thirsty and he's not sharing do
you want water nothing weird are you
drink
well there's one there that we serve to
people oh I'll have some after yes
we're going to watch the trees at least
that games come for a game called wild
mmm you know wild is a great way to
describe myself I like the thing on a
pretty wild guy I went to my first rave
yeah yeah I'm talking a lot of a lot
coke a lot of hats of LSD every [ __ ]
crazy shrimps how are you alive meth
pills like nothing like crystal meth
like you know like reeling a little
little it was it was that much only
after Breaking Bad you gotta try it at
least once
nope don't ever try talk about a message
what I used to live in Spokane it was
like number two on the chart for the
worst problem no it sounds all serious
crystal meth is not a joking matter no
it's not and there was an explosion it's
like a block away from me once yeah
anyway I think that's what this game
deals with my station
everything about them is being wild
thinking the music's beautiful
what
he'll head is the skeleton
oh don't be alive
Oh
dude I've been waiting to see something
like this I'm not even joking us like
this kind of world and stuff Wow
what is any of this I don't know but I
love the world I love it because I've
been waiting to see something that was
like this I was good I'm going to see
something that was like it crosses like
a human world in an animal world but
they live like amongst each other it
just seems like that they have like oh
this animal has authority over these
humans but there's also these kinds of
humans and stuff it just looks like a
[ __ ] awesome world
I mean pun aside but that looked wild no
it did it did the name is very accurate
to what that is I wish we knew who we
were playing as or who we could play us
still like I love the world of it all I
have no idea what its gonna be about at
all but I am just so [ __ ] intrigued
by everything about this oh yeah dude it
like that's like that very moving
trailer yeah it's like its own nature
and instead cuz it's a hybrid of like
real animals within fantasy animals
enough and giant skeletons as yeah like
it doesn't make sense none of it's just
like I don't know what's going on but I
love it yeah yeah I mean how much more
we can say then give us much info it's
very celtic celtic well subscribers
recommended it so if we say we like it
we win brownie points i try that yes
they did some brownies but not the kind
you like what the kind I love Oh ones
with peanuts other definitely peanuts in
there yeah oh oh jokes hey guys if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects is oh do
or reject doors and you can subscribe to
dance channel a gaming channel
that's Siebert Oh Chanel I don't know
the combination Spanish yeah
now it's like a beauty boutique that
would be cool you should open up your
own perfume line newly Sons it's it's
sauna Senate Sun up my bad
damnit I read better Newlands Sunnah
that a whole name wrong am I ever gonna
get a shout out from the rejects
party on no Newland Sun up you're not
gonna get a shout out but you are gonna
get a podium yeah party you are new in
suna you have a fun time okay but no
shadow not mentioning you party on Garth
what's that so Wayne's World yes I feel
stupid
we need to say party on Wayne right now
party on Wayne thank you I hope I got
Garth right ders it's not girth it
should be girth it's most definitely
shouldn't be mm I feel like birth is a
word that stands for something else ah
that's how I know it Joe Connell can i
have a shout out to you with the good
work Joe O'Connell is the twin brother
of Jerry O'Connell actually mmm he is
the least successful one he's the one
with like the really bad curly hair
glasses very overweight wears a suit to
work but hates his job and other than
that the only thing it really has
respect for is being Jerry O'Connell's
brother but you know man you're an
individual and you're human being and
you know just stay in there and maybe
one day someone will fall in love with
you but the record I think everything he
just said was not right
I'm pretty sure all right the guy's name
is Joe O'Connell what else is it gonna
be
you get one video and this is that one
all right thanks proxy 13 mm-hmm can I
get a shout-out proxy 13 I'm afraid that
you might be 13 years old
proxy sounds like it could be a girl so
I'm gonna be very mature about this and
tell you yeah
I cannot reply back for another five
years
that's appropriate right that's
appropriate but just seems a little
creepy it just just so you know you can
like say you can like communicate with
people under the age of 18 you just
can't yes live you're saying I could
still have like a conversation about
other things you can still talk about I
don't know one direction I could talk
about one direction you talk you can
talk about one direction
yeah I hate one direction oh can I could
like who's telling you right now I don't
like one direction it's because that's
because you're over the age of 16 and
and male like they're not something
where I'm like oh I hate them because
everyone else hates them I see them and
I hate them like it was just pure
loathing
we will never work together one
direction but proxy 13 hey we might be
able to have a conversation you might be
a guy out for all I know
in that case I could give you plenty of
sex advice or maybe it's just proxy
footage what's that
editing jokes ah I got it where that
will appeal